Вітаю!
Сьогодні ми на уроці географії.
Мене звати Чемеріс Світлана
І ми починаємо подорож
по материку Євразія.
Євразія – це материк, на
якому живемо ми з Вами.
Сьогодні ми розпочнемо знайомство
з його географічним положенням.
Назва Євразія походить від назви
двох частин світу – Європа і Азія.
Перша з них, за однією з
гіпотез, з`явилася ще до нашої ери
і означала захід або темрява.
Тобто, це були землі,
за якими ховалося сонце.
Інша частина – Азія походила
від «Асі» або «Азу» і означала схід,
тобто землі, за яких з`являлося
сонце. Дивимось на екран.
Межа між Європою та Азією проходить:
по східним підніжжям Уральських гір
долиною річки Урал або Эмбе,
Каспійському морю, Кумо-Маницькій западині
і через моря Азовське, Чорне та
Середземне, протоками Босфор і Дарданелли.
Як Ви думаєте, яке озеро знаходиться
одночасно в двох частинах світу?
Я думаю, ви помітили, що
це Каспійське море-озеро.
Дивлячись на фізичну карту, можна
помітити одразу, що розміри материка
суттєво відрізняються від
інших. Це материк гігант.
Його площа становить близько
1,3 площі всього суходолу.
Такі величезні розміри не могли не
позначитись на особливостях його природи.
Давайте почнемо розбиратися - які
саме особливості положення материка
і як вони вплинули на його природу.
Увага на екран.
На слайді ми бачимо план характеристики
географічного положення материка.
Я думаю, він вам добре знайомий,
оскільки це останній материк в
курсі 7-го класу, який ви вивчаєте.
Однак, давайте пригадаємо - які
ключові моменти ми маємо розглянути,
вивчаючи положення материка?
Нам потрібно розглянути розташування
материка відносно екватора
і його протяжність з півночі на південь.
Півкулі в я ких знаходиться материк та
географічні пояси, в яких лежить материк.
Також - протяжність материка із
заходу на схід та його розташування його
відносно Гринвіцького
або нульового меридіану.
Також ми маємо звернути увагу на океани,
моря та морські течії,
що омивають материк.
Ну, і, звісно, потрібно
розглянути найближчі материки
і шляхи сполучення з ними.
Давайте починаємо з 1 пункту.
Увага на екран.
Крайня північна точка, мис Челюскін
знаходиться на півострові Таймир.
А крайня південна точка - мис Піай
знаходиться на півострові Малакка.
Якщо Ви пам`ятаєте курс 6 класу,
то ви вивчали визначення
географічних координат.
Давайте спробуємо визначити,
які географічні координати
у крайньої північної і
крайньої південної точки.
Як ми це робимо? Ми пригадуємо,
що спочатку ми визначаємо
географічну широту, яка
буває північна і південна.
І рухаємося від екватора.
Знаходимо екватор і бачимо,
що крайня північна точка, вона
знаходиться на півночі від екватора,
вона має північну широту. Тепер
потрібно з`ясувати - скільки градусів.
Знаходимо найближчу паралель.
Бачимо, що це 70 гардусів
і знаходимо наступну
паралель – це 80 градусів.
Бачимо, що вона ближче до
80 грудусу північної широти.
Таким чином ми можемо
визначити, що крайня північна точка
має широту 77 градусів північної широти.
Але ми маємо і іншу
координату – це довгота.
Довгота визначається
відносно нульового меридіану.
Ось він у нас - нульовий меридіан.
І ми бачим, що наші крайні точки
знаходяться на схід
від нульового меридіану,
тому ми можемо одразу
сказати, що це - східна довгота.
А тепер визначаємо - скільки градусів.
Знаходимо два найближчі меридіани
– це 100 градусів і 110 градусів.
І дивимось - до якої ближче знаходиться.
Це 104 градуси східної довготи.
Так само ми можемо визначити і
координати крайньої південної точки.
Ми бачимо, що вона поруч біля екватору,
тому це 1 градус північної широти.
І так само ми знаходимо два
найближчі меридіани
Ось ми проводимо вниз, тут підписано
це 100 градусів і 110 градусів.
І бачимо, що, довгота
103 градуси східної довготи.
Але яка протяжність
материка із півночі на південь?
Це має суттєві географічні наслідки.
Давайте спробуємо визначити самостійно,
не дивлячись в підручник. Яким
чином ми можем це зробити?
Дивимось на дошку.
Ми пам’ятаємо із курсу 6-го класу
Що один градус довготи
дорівнює 111.3 км
Для того щоб визначити
протяжність материка в градусах
Нам потрібно знати крайню
північну і крайню південну точку
А зокрема координату,
яка називаеться «широта»
Беремо крайню північну точку,
це 77 градусів північної широти
Мінус широту крайньої південної точки
Це один градус північної широти
І отримуємо з вами
протяжність материка в градусах
Для того, щоб визначити
протяжність материка в кілометрах
Нам потрібно протяжність
в градусах помножити на
Кількість кілометрів в одному градусі
Таким чином ми 76
градусів множимо на 111.3 км
I отримуємо з вами протяжність
нашого материка в кілометрах
Це 8 458 кілометрів
Отже, ми пригадали як
визначаються координати
та протяжність материка
в градусах і кілометрах.
Якщо глянути на карту, то ми бачимо,
що є ще якась одна крайня точка.
Це крайня острівна точка – мис Флігелі.
Який знаходиться в архіпелазі
Земля Франца Иосифа
Крайня південна острівна
точка знаходиться в межах
Малайського архіпелагу і
заходить в південну півкулю.
Таким чином, якщо розглядати
положення материка стосовно екватора
і розташування його в
північній або південній півкулі,
ми можемо зробити висновок,
що Євразія знаходиться повністю
в північній півкулі і лише острови
заходять в південну півкулю
до 11 градусу південної широти.
Який географічний
наслідок із такого положення?
Ми бачимо, що материк
знаходиться в усіх географічних поясах
від арктичного до екваторіального.
Якщо розглядати крайні західні точки і
протяжність материка з заходу на схід,
то бачимо, що і тут Євразія
єрекордсменом. Увага на екран.
Крайня західна точка мис Рока
знаходиться на Піренейському півострові
і крайня східна точка мис Дежньова
знаходиться на Чукотському півострові,
і протяжність між ними
становить близько 16000 км.
Така велика протяжність з заходу на схід
також позначається на
природних умовах материка.
А саме - в межах одного поясу
вздовж паралелі у нас будуть
різні природні умови і сформовані
різні природні комплекси.
З цим ми з Вами познайомимось з
вами трошки пізніше на наступних уроках,
коли будемо вивчати
клімат і природні зони Євразії.
Отже, якщо розглядати положення Євразії
відносно нульового
або Гринвіцького
меридіану, то ми бачимо, що
більша частина
знаходиться в східній півкулі.
І крайній захід, і крайній схід
знаходиться в західній півкулі.
І навіть якщо подивитись на
координати крайніх точок
західної і східної, то бачимо, що
зазначена саме західна довгота.
Оскільки ми з Вами визначили
крайні точки материка
і пригадали як це робиться, пригадайте,
будь ласка, і спробуйте самостійно
визначити координати крайніх
острівних точок, використовуючи атлас.
Таким чином рухаемося далі
Переходимо до пункту
характеристики графічного положення,
які стосуються океанів,
які омивають наш материк.
Якщо ми поглянемо на карту, то
ми бачимо, що Євразію омивають
чотири океани: Атлантичний, Північний
Льодовитий, Індійський та Тихий.
І тут слід згадати поняття
«порізаність берегової лінії»,
оскільки це має важливе значення
і наслідки для природи материка.
Я думаю, що ви вчили - що
таке порізаність берегової лінії.
Вона визначається кількістю островів
і півостровів вздовж узбережжя,
наскільки глибоко води
океану вдаються в суходіл.
Якщо ми поглянемо знову
на карту, то ми побачимо,
що води Атлантичного океану
глибоко вдаються в суходіл
і тут у нас утворилися ряд півостровів:
Балканський, Аппенінський,
Піренейський, Скандинавський.
Також вздовж узбережжя
острови: Великобританія, Ірландія.
Північний Льодовитий океан
не так глибоко вдається в суходіл.
Бачимо тут переважають окраїнні
моря: Баренцеве море, море Лаптєвих,
Східносибірське море. Виділяються острови:
Нова Земля, Земля Франца
Йосифа, Новосибірські острови.
На сході материка також бачимо
численні окраїнні моря: Охотське,
Японське, Східнокитайське,
які відділені від Тихого
океану дугами островів.
Так - це Курильські
острови, Японські острови.
Також тут бачимо півострів Камчатка,
острів Сахалін, півострів Корея.
На Південному сході
сформувався Малайський архіпелаг
– один із більших архіпелагів світу.
На Півдні материк омиває
Індійський океан і тут виділяються
три великі півострови – це
Індокитай, Індостан та Аравійський.
І глибоко вдається в суходіл:
Аравійське море, Бенгальська затока,
Червоне море і Перська затока.
Якщо дивитись на порізаність
берегової лінії, то найбільший вплив
на природу материка
має Атлантичний океан.
Вплив Атлантики відчувається
аж до Уральських гір.
Посилення впливу Атлантичного
океану сприяє і західне перенесення.
Пригадайте, з північної Америки
в яких широтах діють західні вітри?
Так, це помірні широти і значна
частина Євразії знаходиться
також в помірному поясі, тому
тут також є вплив західних вітрів.
Іншим чинником, який не перешкоджає
впливу Атлантичного океану,
є розташування гірських систем.
Як бачимо, гірські системи
розташовані таким чином,
що вони не створюють значної перешкоди
руху повітря з Атлантичного океану.
Але також вони і не створюють
бар`єру для холодного,
відносно сухого повітря з
Північного Льодовитого океану.
Якщо говорити про Тихий та
Індійський океани, то їх вплив
обмежений високими гірськими системами
відносно недалеко від узбережжя.
Які течії омивають материк Євразія?
Згадаємо, що червоним кольором
на карті позначають теплі течії,
синім кольором позначають холодні течії.
Давайте знайдемо - які течії
омивають материк Євразія.
В першу чергу це -
Північноатлантична течія,
яка є продовженням течії Гольфстрім.
Якщо ми дивимось на Тихий океан, то
ми бачимо також,
що тепла течія Куросіо
і Павнічнопасатна течія.
Далі на Півдні материка
ми знаходимо Мусонну течію
і також в Атлантичному океані
бачимо холодну Канарську течію.
Таким чином давайте підведемо підсумок.
Яким чином розташування і розміри материка
впливають на його природні умови?
Увага на екран.
Пам`ятаємо, що найбільший
вплив у нас тут Атлантичного океану.
На цьому ми з Вами завершили частину,
яка стосується географічного положення
і можемо сміливо перейти до
історії дослідження материка.
В 6 класі ви вивчали історію географічних
відкриттів і ділили його на періоди.
Увага на екран.
Античний, Середньовічний,
Великих географічних
відкриттів, Новий і Новітній час
Давайте історію Євразії також
ділити на відповідні періоди
і притримуватися такого ж поділу
Євразію називають Старим світом.
І це не дивно, оскільки відомості
про материк зустрічаються
ще в працях давньогрецьких вчених.
Середньовіччя – це був складний
період в Європі для розвитку науки.
Це був період панування Церкви.
То відкривачами нових
земель були паломники,
учасники хрестових походів, купці.
Одним із таких купців був Марко Поло,
який разом із своїм батьком і
дядьком вирушили на схід Азії.
Це були перші європейці,
які відвідали східні регіони Азії.
Увага на екран.
Ми бачимо на карті їхній маршрут
Після повернення Марко Поло,
будучи ув`язненим, у в`язниці
надиктував свої спогади,
все що він бачив в Східній Азії.
І хоча до винайдення друкарської
машинки було ще дуже далеко,
але його книга була перекладена
різними мовами і це було
майже єдине джерело інформації
про Східну Азію на той час.
Іншим відомим мандрівником
середньовіччя був Ібн Батута.
Ось ми його бачимо на слайді
Для XIV століття пройти 120000 км,
подорожуючи 30 років - це було рекордом.
За цей період Ібн Батута відвідав:
Аравійський півострів, Перську
затоку, Центральну Азію,
через гори Афганістану дійшов до
Індії і відвідав півострів Індокитай.
Тепер переходимо до періоду
великих географічних відкриттів.
Епоха великих географічних
відкриттів, ми пам`ятаємо,
це кінець XV середина XVII століття.
Розглядаючи період великих
географічних відкриттів,
слід згадати звичайно
подорож Васко да Гама,
який відкрив морський шлях до Індії.
Ми бачимо на карті його маршрут
І це прискорило колонізацію
Індії європейцями.
В той час, коли європейці
вже відкрили Америку,
здійснили першу навколосвітню подорож,
величезні простори Азії
були для них загадкою.
Вони не були відкриті,
вони не були відомі.
І тільки після того як
Єрмак перетнув Урал
– це стало поштовхом для освоєння
європейцями азійської частини Євразії.
З 1630 року почалися походи
козаків землепроходців.
Зокрема, це Москвітін, Єрофей
Хабаров, Василь Поярков
– вони вийшли до узбережжя
Тихого океану і річки Амур.
Також варто згадати Федора
Попова та Семена Держньова,
які вперше пройшли Беринговою
протокою і на карті з`явилася
північна східна окраїна Євразії.
Увага на екран.
Тепер давайте розглянемо
дослідників нового часу.
Саме з нового часу починається
період наукових досліджень Євразії.
І тут варто відмітити першу і
другу Камчатську експедицію
на чолі Вітуса Беринга
та Олексія Чірікова.
Також варто згадати
Велику Північну експедицію,
яка тривала 10 років - з 1733 по 1743 рр.
І, в результаті
діяльності цієї експедиції,
були нанесені північні райони Сибіру.
Був досліджений північний
морський шлях і доведено
неможливість пересування ним постійно,
використання його
транспортного, торгового шляху.
Але в то й же час величезний масив
інформації, яку зібрала ця експедиція,
ще наступні 200 років було дуже
важливим джерелом інформації
про Північний Льодовитий
океан, про рух криги,
про температуру води та інші
дані, які стосуються узбережжя
Північного Льодовитого океану Євразії.
Не дивлячись на значну
кількість дослідників, які відкривали
різні частини материка
Євразія, до середини XIX століття
Центральна Азія залишалась білою плямою.
У дослідженнях
Центральної Азії слід відмітити
Миколу Пржевальського та Петра Семенова.
Увага на екран.
Зокрема, Петро Семенов
досліджував район Тянь-Шаню,
озеро Іссик-Куль, він описав
висотну поясність Тянь-Шаню
і здійснив до Центральної
Азії дві експедиції.
За свої досягнення і значний
вклад у дослідження цього регіону
йому дозволи додати до
свого прізвища Тянь-Шанський.
Тому сьогодні мі бачимо саме -
Петро Семенов Тянь-Шанський
Микола Пржевальський також
досліджував регіон Центральної Азії.
Зокрема, він відвідав
пустелю Гобі, гори Тибету,
відкрив витоки двох таких великих
азіатських річок як Хуанхе та Янцзи.
Він здійснив чотири
подорожі до Центральної Азії.
Звісно, це не всі дослідники, які
відкривали різні куточки Євразії,
описували нові види, збирали
колекції гірських порід. Увага на екран.
На цьому ми закінчуємо ознайомлення
з географічним положенням
материка Євразія.
Ваше домашнє завдання буде:
визначити координати крайніх точок,
які ми з вами не визначили під час уроку
і вміти показувати елементи
берегової лінії за переліком,
який ви бачите на слайді.
Дякую за роботу! До побачення.